so i'm going to go back to some of the
rules and you'll see that a lot of the
rules are combined
um in the in the things that i'm saying
and you'll see why they overlap
so another one is don't bury the lead
you want to id that call to action
right off the bat everyone is very
impatient and in school they taught us
if you'll remember when we're writing an
essay for example that you have this
long introductory
paragraph or two kind of laying out you
know
some preparation of when your ideas are
are going to come
together and then at the end the very
end of the paper is when like the whole
you know exciting revelation comes so
that's not the way people write or read
anymore you have to put it all up front
so what i like to say actually is that
writing is four parts editing and one
part vomiting so you vomit first you get
it out all in the page
and then you want to spend the hard time
editing right
and the reason that you want to do that
is because most people do bury the lead
right away so you want to think to
yourself okay the first two
sentences the first five words can
probably just
be 86 altogether and then you'll get
right to the meat of your message
faster so for example i'm a tom petty
fan
um i get my hair cut like like tom petty
by accident all the time
and so i'm saying here's the difference
for you you have to see the last dance
now
versus see the last dance now so
do you see how i don't need this in the
beginning i can just
get rid of that and then here's the
bonus i'm actually creating a call to
action
out of a sentence because when you push
the verb first
you get that command vibe going on
you're the authority right
it's all about getting people to do what
you want them to do